oh
um
the white house response and the trump
campaign response really has been to
mock the democratic national
convention as well to poke fun at joe
biden's stay-at-home policy
the press secretary kelley mcinerney on
her non-official twitter account
tweeting last night
for the first two days of the democratic
national convention president donald
trump has traveled to four states
6 596 miles sleepy joe biden has
traversed
an undisclosed number of steps from his
basement wondering if joe got
6596 steps in today
kellyanne conway the white house
counselor this morning is zeroing in on
the 62nd address by alexandria
that bernie sanders really was
procedural she did not mention
joe biden at all during that speech and
she well could have
so we're not quite clear about what the
reason for that admission was
this morning the white house chief of
staff mark meadows taking aim at john
kerry's
scathing critique of president trump
the president we know campaign events
today though he's got a big one tomorrow
he's got a campaign event
just outside of joe biden's hometown of
scranton pennsylvania
we will hear from the president later on
today he's got one of his
briefing question and answer sessions at
5 30 which in and of itself
draws a sharp contrast with joe biden
harrison was not taking any questions
thank you
okay
you
i think
foreign
your life
okay
you
foreign
two minute warning
you
hello everyone where is nancy pelosi
the house is in recess house and senate
democrats left town after
failing to compromise and make a deal to
provide relief to the american people
while nancy pelosi and her colleagues
went home this president remained
hard at work president trump took
executive action including
stopping evictions providing
unemployment insurance
pausing student loan payments cutting
the payroll tax which put
money in the pockets of all americans
democrats apparently were unable to
stick around to make a deal
now suddenly democrats will be rushing
back to washington
but why the answer the united states
postal service
it's a stunning turn of events democrats
went home after accomplishing nothing
no deal on stimulus checks no deal on
small business relief
no deal on eviction protections the
concerns of everyday americans
were not the concerns of democrats on
capitol hill
so where is nancy pelosi she and her
democrat colleagues will be back in
washington soon to pursue their latest
manufactured crisis
the postal service democrats denied a 10
billion offer for the u.s postal service
by this president before they went on
recess but now they're back to pursue
the latest democrat manufactured crisis
it's sad but it's clear where democrats
priorities stand
and with that i'll take questions john
uh
kaley looking ahead to potential action
at the united nations will the president
dispatch
the secretary of state to go to the u.n
to invoke the snap-back clause
on sections yeah so um i have no
announcements and i won't get ahead of
the president but
what i will say is the president has
said that he will be willing to invoke
the snapback option soon and i'll leave
that to him
the president said this week the only
way we lose this election is if the
election is rigged it
begs the question does the president
believe there's any circumstance under
which he could lose the election
fairly the president believes he's done
a great job for the american people and
he believes that will show in november
he believes
that voter fraud is real in line with
what we see
all across the country particularly with
mail-in ballots
which are prone to fraud yes thank you
very much two questions for you firstly
um
given the president's tweet on goodyear
and lashing out at them um is the beast
still going to be using goodyear tires
i'm not going to comment on security
matters okay and then i want to follow
up with a question that i asked the
president uh last week but he didn't
answer
i asked him about so i wanted to know
have you ever heard the president talk
about queuing on
and what does he think of the conspiracy
theory no i've never heard of that
there's a lot of media focus on that but
certainly never heard of that from the
president
yes kaylee just a follow-up um on
on what uh my colleague said over there
with regard to the president
saying make sure to get out and vote
because the only way we're going to lose
this election is if the election is
rigged
does the president is the president
saying if he doesn't win this election
that he will not accept the results
unless he wins
the president has always said he'll see
what happens
and make a determination in the
aftermath it's the same thing he said
last november he wants a free election a
fair election and he wants confidence in
the results of the election particularly
when you have states like nevada doing
mass mail out voting
uh to their voting roles and when they
tried this in the primary it was a
massive failure ballots were piled up in
trash cans ballots were pinned
to apartment dart boards and with that
being the system
uh the president wants to take a hard
look at this and make sure that these
are fair
uh election results and not subject to
fraud yes
tell us if the white house has reached
out to pelosi or the democrats
to talk over the next couple of days
about stimulus yeah so i have no updates
on
the personal conversations that we've
been having but what i'll say is this
is i know the speaker is interested in
potentially a skinny bill
with post office funding but what we
want here at the white house is we're
certainly open
to post office funding we did after all
offer that 10 billion dollars that was
turned down so we're open to that but
what we want to see in there
is relief for the american people who
are hurt through no fault of their own
for unemployed americans we want to see
enhanced unemployment
insurance ppp we want to see small
businesses get taken care of that money
goes directly to payroll so to pay
workers and
thus keep jobs um and we're interested
in seeing stimulus checks go out to the
american people
as well on the post office are you able
to share if you're
at the white house is open to the 25
billion dollars that the democrats are
proposing or is 10 billion
the cap no we don't have a cap we're
certainly open to looking at the 25
billion but we want included in there
relief for the american people that thus
far speaker pelosi
has been entirely uninterested in as
this president has taken unilateral
action to protect americans subject to
eviction to protect americans who are
unemployed
to protect americans via a tax cut
through payroll deferral so this
president's taken action still
we're waiting on a reckless speaker
pelosi to get back and do her job
yes just to follow up on that and then i
have another question um
are there other things that the
president could do in the realm of
the executive action to address this
problem with the postal service to
ensure that they've got sufficient
funding is there anything that he could
do to do
to sort of fill the gap so the post
office um
does have sufficient funding through
2021
and they do currently have cash on hand
they've been given that 10
billion dollar line of credit through
the cares act
so that's important to note um and look
we're looking at the post office funding
um to do with speaker pelosi but that
must also include
um money for our hard-working americans
as well and the president just to
underscore this mission yesterday
uh that he wants to protect postal
workers these are great hard-working
americans and he wants to make
the post office solvent um and to
protect those post office jobs and he
mentioned
on amazon needing to raise the price of
packages for amazon as a way
to help the solvency with the post
office
with the recent agreement between israel
and the united arab emirates
there is great interest on the part of
the emiratis to purchase f-35
what was the president's position on
selling those
high-end aircraft to the emiratis at
this point and would that
require congressional changes to remove
the qualitative military edge
uh that is guaranteed to israel in this
moment so we don't confirm or comment on
proposed defense sales or transfers
until they're formally notified to
congress
um to circle back on your first point
too about post office funding i did want
to highlight
um a piece that was written by ruth
goldway who's a retired chairwoman and
commissioner
of the u.s postal regulatory commission
i believe it was in the new york times
and she said quote that the post office
has access to about 25 billion in cash
its own forecasts predict that it will
have enough money to operate
into 2021. so this notion that there's
this emergency
for which nancy pelosi needs to rush
back to capitol hill to solve
is a farce it is false the real thing
that's happening here is nancy pelosi is
feeling pressure from her members
from her constituents because she's not
delivered relief for the american people
and president trump has yes paul thank
you kaylee today the president
encouraged americans
not to buy goodyear tires suggesting
that they had a ban on maga hats but it
appears
that their policy is just a ban on
political speech it's pretty common for
most companies
so why is the president retaliating
against a private company for their
dress code and potentially jeopardizing
american jobs
so goodyear needs to come out and
clarify their policy there was an image
they failed to clear yes i did see their
statements which still still
failed to clarify their policy what
happened is there was an image that was
put out
that showed that certain speech was
acceptable black lives matter
insignia for instance but what was not
allowed was blue lives matter what was
not allowed was maga hats
what was clearly targeted was a certain
ideology they have not denied that that
image
was presented at one of their facilities
and they need to come out racial
equality racial justice that is okay but
not
political speech that's pretty standard
across the board right now that's not
that unusual
did the president even reach out to
goodyear before they came out and said
equity issues
as far as i'm concerned blue lives
matter is an equity issue there have
been police officers across this country
that have been targeted because they
wear the badge look no further than
dallas where five police officers died
so black lives matter an organization
who's
in their dc branch said black lives
matter means to fund the police
one of their presidents in new york said
we will burn down the system
we all remember in 2015 the yelling of
pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon
out of black lives matter rally
that speech is allowed but blue lives
matter is not allowed
and i will stand at this podium and say
blue lives matter is an equity issue
and and goodyear needs to come out and
acknowledge
the reason he called for the boycott was
over magga maga is pretty much
unanimous with blue lives matter these
days if you've seen the endorsements
yeah
does the white house support rolling
back those existing operational changes
that louis
de joy have has done at the postal
service like those mail sorting machines
he said he would pause uh the
operational changes going forward but
does he do you guys support rolling back
the ones that have already affected mail
delivery
so the president made his position clear
on this yesterday and it is
uh making the post office solvent via
amazon package rates being raised
um it's important to note how this works
so for letters magazines catalogs the
post office can only
raise prices by the rate of inflation
whereas with packages and commercial
freight
uh like amazon they can raise those
competitive prices and
uh the postmaster general lewis de joy
has proposed doing just that
because we don't believe that amazon
should be able to push expensive
packages to the post office
and burden them further when they've
already had issues
with funding and push it there but
yet take advantage of the cheaper
shipping it's a business model that
works for amazon but it's not one that
works for the american people and
clearly not one that works for the post
office
operational changes he's the president's
made clear that amazon he thinks that's
the best way to go and i'll let him
answer any further on that yes
thanks kelly uh the president last night
congratulated laura loomer for her
primary one in florida
he's also back marjorie taylor green in
georgia both women have expressed
anti-muslim
sentiments does the president endorse
their view of their views of muslims
and does he believe that those views
belong in congress well the president
routinely congratulates people who have
fi
who officially uh get the republican
nomination for congress so he does that
as a matter of course
he hasn't done a deep dive into the
statements by these two particular women
i don't know if he's even seen that but
he supports
the muslim community um he supports the
community of faith more broadly in this
country
i think he could the president said that
klaus has been a consideration in
selecting the white house as the
location for his acceptance speech
on next week and i'm wondering if
um if cost in terms of keeping costs
down for security purposes is a
consideration when he's selecting
when to travel to his homes in florida
and new jersey
um look the president made clear that he
wants to look at cost with regard to the
convention he
always tries to um but the president is
entitled at times to leave the white
house and he's done that just like every
past
president has yeah thank you kaylee can
you confirm that the u.s china
trade deal phase one talks with
ambassador lighthizer are still on track
and if so do you have a date for this
yeah so the trade representatives um do
speak and the president
has expressed his displeasure uh with
china with regard to kobit and the
pandemic
i don't have a date for any official
talks but it is safe to say um should
they continue it would be between the
trade representatives
back back to vidya for a second accept
the issue of the beast aside
when the president says don't buy
goodyear tires
get better tires for far less is he
imploring that to his supporters
or is that the official policy of the
u.s federal government that the
president has directed
saying do not buy goodyear tires going
forward
the president was talking um to his
supporters when he tweeted that
in particular and look this president
will never apologize for standing with
law enforcement
um he won't he thinks it's unacceptable
if you can wear a black lives matter hat
guess what you should be able to wear a
blue lives matter one too particularly
when our police officers are targeted
like they were in dallas particularly
when david dorn lost his life amid these
riots he will always stand
against our police officers and blue
lives matter for some reason not being
an
equity issue as goodyear uh appears to
maintain
so for all the fleets out there that
have goodyear tires on them that
inevitably
need to be replaced that is fine go
ahead and purchase i i haven't spoken
to him about that in particular you can
ask him later in the 5 10 hours yes
thank you kaylee uh as the white house
continues to spearhead its vision and
its
victories for middle east peace what
commitments does the white house
hope to uh establish with the visit of
the prime minister from iraq
tomorrow yeah so that visit we're very
much looking forward um to that tomorrow
um the president looks forward to
welcoming
prime minister kadami to the white house
the u.s
iraq strategic partnership is based upon
a common goal for a
stable secure and prosperous middle east
and iraq is a key partner to the u.s on
a range of regional security issues
including the enduring defeat of isis so
all of those matters
will be discussed tomorrow yes john the
president has been very bullish on
the potential of convalescent plasma
and it appeared as though the fda was
poised to issue an emergency euthanasia
use
authorization for convalescent plasmid
but a number of the president's top
advisors in the medical field including
doctors collins and fauci said
let's put a hold on the eua it's too
early we don't yet know
about the true efficacy of convalescent
plasma does the president agree
with putting off the emergency youth
authorization or
is he of a different mind of it yeah so
i haven't spoken to the president about
that particular eua
um you can ask him that later this
afternoon
um but i did um follow up and with the
fda on a testing issue
and i wanted to look into the average
time for a point of care test because
you all um ask often about our point of
care or more rapid tests
and the average time for point of care
test from submission to the fda
to decision for covid related rapid
point-of-care tests
was 20 days and by comparison that for
ebola flu and strep point of care test
was over 100 days
so this fda under this president has
managed to prove these rapid
point-of-care tests that you all ask
about
at a rate five times faster than for
ebola
flu and strep which have taken more than
100 days on average
i mean just before i walked out here
attorney general barr
announced some very good new news last
week of course we learned that
the suspected killer of legend talafero
was charged which was very encouraging
to see operation legend was of course
named after legend talafero the
four-year-old
boy who was shot and killed in his bed
this has been going on for six weeks
there have been a thousand federal
agents from fbi dea
atf and u.s marshals working side by
side with state and local authorities
operation legend is a very good example
of cooperation and action
which is a sharp contrast to those who
merely express empty
sentiments or worse hold blatant
disregard for the unacceptable
violence in our cities of which many
children have fallen victim to
uh the president cares the president
wants law and order restored he wants
peace in our streets so this president
took action
and today the attorney general can
announce under the leadership of this
president
that federal agents have made over 1 000
arrests
as part of operation legend many of
these arrests are for violent state
crimes including 90
homicides and as a.g bar notes that
means 90 killers would still be on the
streets today without the law and order
actions of president trump
um and as the mother of legend tell a
pharaoh said
this scene she said quote my one and
only child who fought through open-heart
surgery
at four months is gone due to senseless
gun violence children are supposed to be
our future
and our four-year-old son did not even
make it to kindergarten
i stand here today as a mother fighting
against violence for my son
legend talafero my family and i support
operation legend and we strongly want
our communities and everyone else behind
us
uh today legend tala pharaoh was once
again honored
by the actions of operation legend and
we can thank president trump and the
work of attorney general barr for that
great news
thank you all very much the president
will be back here in the 5 pm
will the president do something about
bounties on american soldiers
you